- [Voiceover] We're told, let f of x
equal g of x over x
squared minus x minus six,
where g of x is a polynomial.
Which of the following is a possible graph
of y equals f of x?
And they give us four choices.
The fourth choice is off right over here.
And like always, pause the video,
and see if you can figure
it out or if you were
having trouble with it as
I start to think about it
with you, pause it anytime,
if you feel inspired.
It's really important to
try to engage in the problem
as opposed to just watch me do it.
But let's start tackling
this now together.
So, this is interesting.
They don't give us a lot of
information about f of x.
If fact, we don't know
what the numerator is.
We just know that it is a polynomial.
Well, that's somewhat valuable.
But they do give us the denominator
and so, we can think about what are
the interesting numbers, what are
the interesting x-values
for the denominator.
In particular, what x-values will make
the denominator equal to zero?
And to do that, we can
factor out the denominator.
So let's see, the coefficient
on the first degree term
is essentially negative one.
We can write negative
one there if we want.
And the constant is negative six.
So if we want to factor that, we can say,
well, what two number,s they're product
is negative six and they
add up to negative one?
Well, negative three times
positive two is negative six.
And negative three plus two
is equal to negative one.
So I can rewrite f of x.
I can say that f of x
is equal to g of x over
x minus three times x plus two.
So the denominator equals zero
for x equals three or
x equals negative two.
That's when the denominator is zero.
So zero denominator. I'll
just write it like that.
And so something makes the
denominator equal to zero.
That tell us that we're either going
to have a vertical asymptote at that point
or we're going to have a
removable discontinuity at that point.
And the way that that would be
a removable discontinuity, let's say,
if we had a removable discontinuity
at x equals three, well
that means that g of x
could be factored into x minus three
times a bunch of other stuff.
If that was the case, the x equals three
would a removable discontinuity.
If x equals three does not
make g of x equal zero.
So, for example, if g of
three does not equal zero,
or g of negative two does not equal zero,
then these would both
be vertical asymptotes.
So let's look at the choices here.
So choice A, we have
one vertical asymptote.
That vertical asymptote is
at x equals negative two.
So it seems, this line,
let me draw this line here.
This vertical asymptote, right over there,
that is a line, x is
equal to negative two.
So at least to be, it
seems to be consistent
with that over there but
what about x equals three?
This one seems completely cool.
This graph is defined at x equals three.
X equals three is right over there
and it seems to be defined there.
And this, f of x, is
clearly not defined at f,
at x is equal to three
because when x equals three,
the denominator is zero and
dividing by zero is not defined.
So even though this has
one vertical asymptote
at an interesting place,
we're going to rule it out
because this graph is
defined at x is equals three,
even though f of x is not.
We would need to see either
a vertical asymptote there
or a removable discontinuity.
Alright, here we have a vertical asymptote
at x is equal to negative two and we have
another vertical asymptote at
x is equal to positive four.
So that doesn't make sense either.
This one, just like the last one,
is actually defined at x equals three.
We that x is equals three,
the function is equal to zero.
But this function? F of
three is not equal to zero.
F of three is undefined.
We're dividing by zero.
So we could rule this out.
Once again, at x equals
three, we need to see
the removable discontinuity
or a vertical asymptote,
because we're not defined there.
Alright, let's see choice C.
We see a vertical asymptote
at x is equal to negative two.
So that looks pretty good.
And we see a removable
discontinuity at x equals three.
So this function is,
this graph is not defined
for x equals three or for
x equals negative two,
which is good because f is not defined
at either of those
points because at either
of those x-values, our f's
denominator is equal to zero.
So this one looks quite interesting.
And this would be consistent.
This one would be consistent
with the, with f of x
being something of the sort of,
so the denominator, we already know.
X minus three times x plus two.
And in the numerator, we would have,
since x minus three is not a vertical as-,
since x equals three isn't
a vertical asymptote,
it's a removable discontinuity, we must
be able to factor, for this one, g of x
into x minus three times something else.
So that's consistent
with this one over here.
So I like this choice.
Now let's look at this choice, choice D.
Choice D has two vertical asymptotes.
One at x is equal to negative one.
This is negative two, so
this, x equals negative one.
And this x is equal to six.
Neither of them are, would coincide
with what make our denominator equal zero,
so we could rule this out as well.
So we could feel really
good about choice C.